What is it that you love about dance?
Everything you need to know is in my dancing.
Everything?
What you saw before...
...is just the beginning.
Welcome to my house.
Think of the House as like a super crew.
Dancers work together, live together,...
...and battle together.
It's crazy, right?
This place is incredible!
Check this. It's the biggest battle ever.
You up for a little competition?
I never lose.
Some people learn to dance.
Others are born to.
People dance because dance can change things.
One move can bring people together.
One move...
...can make you believe like you're something more.
...can set a whole generation free.
We should get to rehearsal.
Oh, that's so sick!